this is a refugee processing center
we're about three kilometers from the
ukrainian border and the corchova
crossing
there is a steady stream of refugees
it's not just that it's not slowing down
it's growing according to the polish
government about 98 000 people crossed
into this country from ukraine on
tuesday alone that pushes the total to
about 450 000 refugees who moved into
poland and that number is expected to
pass the half million mark today now the
refugee numbers from neighboring
countries are one thing but those are
the people who've been able to make it
out to safety there are tens of
thousands displaced inside the country
the european union estimates about 160
000 people have left their homes for
other parts of ukraine predicting what
will happen it says the number of
displaced ukrainians could climb to
around 7 million of course those numbers
are just statistics individually each of
these men women and children are just
people
left their homes behind and are living a
nightmare
because
[Music]
[Music]
it's very bad actually we love ukraine
too much it's our second country and uh
i wish the best for korean i wished our
army our ukrainian army actually to to
beat this situation and to stand up
again they are like in ukrainian we said
about our soldiers like kozak so slava
karina hello
heroin
we are from ecuador and
we come from
health of ukraine because the world is
so
dangerous for all
we are students and i study here in
kharkov
since last year and in another case
since
eight five years
and
we decided to survive because
nobody guarantee our
lives you heard
the tanks the bombs and detonations
of aircrafts come back aircrafts and
then
you only have the possibility to
to
[Music]
keep safe safely
yes this is the situation but this
two days saturday and sunday it's more
difficult
i have
some
friends that
they
are in their
university residence and in other places
but they are not safe
and authorities of my country and from
another countries
not do anything